I have this video
clearly recorded when the weather was nice
and not -10
but I still enjoyed sharing it
most problems outside
like pulling on the leash
falling out to dogs
falling out to cats
have 1 number of things in common
one of them is that De Hond has no contact
makes more with you
so it is super important that you have your dog
and certainly as a puppy
learn to make and keep in touch during the walk
you can do this with food
but I like it when it works without food
that's why I show you in this video
how to use only your body language
can get in touch with your dog
I prefer to practice this when going outside
that's where the walk starts
if your dog learns to make nice contact here
Continue in the walk
benefit a lot from it
also try it with your dog